walk him to this video blitz game
against Joe Jenn FM from Norway it's no
name in them yeah I'm pretty sure I
played it before yep only once and i
lost don't remember though how it went
ok i'll pick up them exchange variation
of the rule not a super exciting line
for black but it's admittedly i'm very
solid for white ok or d3 is very modest
approach deforest normally play TM and
ok i'll take this chance to stop this
once and for all yeah um what white is
probably going to do is try to play 92
and therefore ok playing for before
really ok you can do it i mean but it's
not it's not leading to much but can try
Charles oh we've gotten a frozen queen
side now hmm yeah should I do that I
want to get the night 2d for this lame
and I was wondering if it would have
made some sense to prevent 95 for the
time being by leaving the not only seven
but ok that's it's not a big deal ok
well see three it's not really a move
for white zone I just play the normal
news yeah it's not really a movement of
course he's just playing it yeah I
thought that this does not make much
sense really weakening the structure
it does not really make much sense but
ok it's not like why does losing him
immediately just just to be weakening ok
um what am i doing now I could play a
five opening it up for my bishops yeah
maybe do that hmm not sure that I wanted
to allow a five on just stay put why not
open up the position ok so i get to mmm
interesting yeah come on I'm doing that
I keep it keep it simple approach take
just take on e for two at the end to
take on on FYI get the e5 square
shouldn't be a bit too bad okay well
here 95 a thought should be quite good
if I take on d3 actually is this
possible take on d3 tags on d6 takes on
c2 takes on e 7 hmm probably not young
but ok this is not not bad at all and
after fu for I think there's queen age
for Queen edge form what is it doing
after that g3 m-maybe it's not exactly
great for white I mean hmm I could also
play ok well he will play g6 and
probably night f4 or something like that
mmm yeah Queen Anne Shui looks
attractive but it's not really doing
much check it's not really doing much
the sound is exceptionally an
exceptionally loud need to fix that ok
ok Bishop f4 I wants to exchange if I go
Quinn to f7 i'm attacking on b3 and I'm
threatening g5 looks like a good move
actually threatening g5 winning a piece
cannot take on e5 Queen f1 s checkmate
removes the rook I'll take a form mm
yeah I mean yeah not just g5 and that's
it for the bishop
white resigns yeah that was quick it's
surprised I mean blackest black is
substantially better here of course but
I was not expecting to win so quickly
Queen yeah I'm here Queen h4 looked
really good but it's probably not not so
I'm so great just g3 and night f-4s is
helping him a bit the computer has very
glad I idea on so it's a computer it has
no ideas but it suggests this move and
that's very good really first taking so
that be4 is no Muslim and here when I'm
threatening to take so white needs to
take Bishop takes yeah and this is just
just excellent with those two Bishop and
two bishops and he's got the far worse
pawn structure with three isolated ponds
that are all week that's very nice
actually for black that's better than
then minus or look evaded it keeps it
keeps an advantage but nothing so
decisive but this is after Queen f7
tricky i guess computer wants to play
our queen to be one yeah that's a good
move yeah well that's a good move it
intends to take here and now if i go and
here he will really just take losing a
piece so i have I don't really have a
great great answer here I can take on a
form group takes and go back oh this is
still somewhat better for black but it's
not by far not so good as the computer
suggestion to play c4 that's really a
really excellent yeah what I didn't
really didn't really understand this is
c3 move because it's just weakening
provide and then leading nowhere I mean
okay it's not not fatal or anything but
it gets it gets tricky quickly after f4
f5
the position will open up for blacks
bishops and that this cannot be too
great yeah yeah okay I could have taken
on d3 yet I thought that this sir ok
computer is very cool taking on d6 okay
now i cannot i cannot do this moves and
let's but i think 95 was perfectly okay
this is basically forced a chance to
this already m and demonstrated um begat
Shem okay yo thanks for watching